[Music]
we just sat down with mr. magic Mike
himself and he's got a new project which
actually shows a gordon-levitt but ET on
lines layin Aguilera just had to ask
about canteen side hustle with some hard
liquor that's really going viral I love
that you were surprising people with
your vodka recently with sauce yeah how
much fun was that it was actually pretty
crazy every woman's fantasy open your
front door and the delivery boy is
Channing Tatum thank ya in this case
with the bottle of his brand of vodka
born and bred
I never was it like a delivery boy so I
don't know like did you never know
what's gonna answer the door well you
were never a delivery boy I never was a
delivery boy my parents even had a pizza
place at one point so but I never
delivered a pizza there ordering booze
at like 3 o'clock in the afternoon
either they're about to get wild or
they've been getting wild vodka actually
plays a role in Channing and Joseph
satirical new Amazon series comrade
detective did you do it
is this like I'll put some new dreams
like I'm not drinking and and he goes
vodka then he's like yes it's a
fictional 80's Romanian detective show
Channing and Joseph dub over the lines
in English
bluegrass PD Sam one of the best scenes
in this whole thing is when when your
guys just like stupid drunk drinking
like an entire bottle of vodka not your
vodka cuz it was the 80s in Romania
[Music]
you